humanity's struggle against death has
been our most enduring fight history has
given us one weapon in this existential
battle we fight back with medicine tens
of thousands of years ago our ancestors
scavenged the natural world for remedies
imagine the incredible leaps of faith we
had to take in an effort to ease the
pain mend thebroken revive the sick
medicine was a dark art full of false
starts and false gods when we struck
upon some form of relief it swept like
wildfire through humankind we built on
every success until medicine became a
form of science that's when we
discovered the real killers within a
microscopic army is hidden within our
bodies waging war on our species for
thousands of years medicine is our great
weapon to fight back against invisible
unthinkable death
[Applause]
from superstition to science medicine
has become one of humanity's most
powerful tool and so with each new
challenge we may stumble find a way to
get stronger and smarter feedbacks fatal
diseases and extend our lifespan even
crack open our genetic code this is the
story of how our fight against death has
determined our fate how it became the
driving force of our evolution how our
tireless pursuit of Medicine has made us
modern and even made us superhuman
this is origin
[Music]
mmm
you know
[Music]